welcome to this video the Russian master
Michele is the opponent on let's check
that we care a lager pavia I played him
before definitely um yeah probably an
Enzo ok going for the classical
variation and germany i have to say i'm
not a huge expert them yeah let's play
that simple line I really don't know
they're complicated once that well so
this is the the simple way to go about
it where black usually has good
equalizing chances yep you can offer
that pawn maybe just out of three taking
it is very risky how is he actually able
to play c5 that would be interesting I
mean like quickly probably that's good
before I hope that is a good idea
playing before yeah that's quick him I
was thinking about that that's a bit of
a that's quick c5 yeah maybe rook see
one it's a bit slow ish this development
on the Kings side but I hope he has no
real way to exploit that one issue is
they cannot so easily play Knight to d7
as I have bishop a six in general it's
not so easy for him to develop that
night even with prep moves like c6 and
so on still this Bishop a6 can be
irritating
Wow actually thought that this is
completely non-playable because of
Bishop basics so I go Bishop a6 what is
his idea in the first place if he moves
the rock that takes his seven what is
the point isn't that like I don't get it
and I don't get it so they have no
there's not even account to play with
Bishop before I can really just take
take take the porn okay
we should be four or something I can
just take the the night the night is
hanging on 97 yeah that was a that was
an alternative but should be five
forever looks tricky for him or if he
takes I can always take the seven yeah i
can i can just castle short
maybe this one that's it it seems simple
and now taking the night yeah i was
thinking queen to age three should be
sufficient Bishop g4 Queen g3 is not
helping him and where's the bishop going
I should be for Queen g3 yeah Queen g3
looks good in case of a queen trade
that's very simple winner with the
bishop on 86 dominating the C file so he
cannot really trade queens okay so what
is his plan it's probably bishop sorry
rook rook to e6 but I have bishops e8 so
that's not really problematic and let's
do this double on the C file that also
covers d3 so that Bishop d3 is not going
to happen huh so if i go i can go f3
right and to win material still I don't
see a problem with that f3 Bishop
somewhere efore and then winning winning
that piece yeah pawn takes rook takes be
1e takes f3 I have rook f1 yeah I think
so I don't see a problem with that all
my pieces are unprotected this is why I
was a bit hesitant but I don't really
see a problem a 6 I mean this is really
something if you see that all your
pieces are unprotected it's a good
moment to just yeah take stock and make
sure that nothing bad is really
happening
so it took their let's see how to do
that you can check me on d 10 mb 1 mm we
are Queenie ones maybe a move covering
all that 25 maybe yeah maybe 25 but a FB
should be too if everything else fails I
go boo should be too yeah check your
mind check your king age 7 and 25 maybe
time morning chats do that Queenie 5 you
can check me twice but I can always go
to g3 right snow no nothing nothing bad
happening to me
g3 is pretty safe
and I'm threatening check made myself
Luke age a drupe g8 Queen g7 made so he
cannot check me and then play some kind
of silent move there
black resins out of any any kind of
trick see if he essentially has to trade
queens now yeah night 97 was just just a
lemon there what has he have to do yeah
that [ __ ] thats that's what he saw him
playing yeah that's that's a good one
now maybe a five I don't think c5 is
working maybe this this and ok he wants
to go yeah a five that that he played
that black is certainly okay yeah
probably something like that check yeah
I think this is it this is about equal
there is no reason why any insight could
can can claim an advantage here night
III a queen a three or a four may be
here I'm not quite sure maybe here yeah
it's equal it's just equal this line is
a bit to be tame from the white point of
view but I don't know the sharp one so I
went for that and okay after Bishop a
six why this is basically winning cheeks
and takes here Jim he really has little
in terms of improvement of course he
doesn't need to blunder the piece but
it's difficult to give it wise i have
the C file that's a very strong
obstructing piece and blackheads no
counterplay cannot do this because of
Bishop to see eight and he's losing the
exchange on top of everything
you know something check f3 is helping
against this even made him yeah okay 97
was was basically giving it away in in
one move okay well thanks for watching